-Hey, YouTube!
There should be music behind me.
That's alright.
It's BTS week here at the
"Tonight Show,"
and everyday,
we've been bringing you
amazing new performances
from the group.
Here now to perform
their smash hit, "Dynamite,"
which has topped the chart
in over 100 countries, BTS!
♪♪
[ Click ]
-♪ Cause I-I-I'm
in the stars tonight ♪
♪ So watch me bring the fire
and set the night alight ♪
♪ Shoes on,
get up in the morn ♪
♪ Cup of milk,
let's rock and roll ♪
♪ King Kong, kick the drum ♪
♪ Rolling on
like a rolling stone ♪
♪ Sing song
when I'm walking home ♪
♪ Jump up to the top, LeBron ♪
♪ Ding-dong,
call me on my phone ♪
♪ Ice tea,
and a game of ping-pong ♪
♪ This is getting heavy ♪
♪ Can you hear the bass boom?
I'm ready ♪
♪ Life is sweet as honey ♪
♪ Yeah, this beat cha-ching
like money ♪
♪ Disco overload, I'm into that,
I'm good to go ♪
♪ I'm diamond,
you know I glow up ♪
♪ Hey, so, let's go ♪
♪ 'Cause I-I-I'm
in the stars tonight ♪
♪ So watch me bring the fire
and set the night alight ♪
♪ Shining through the city
with a little funk and soul ♪
♪ Light it up like dynamite,
whoa ♪
♪ Bring a friend, join the crowd
Whoever wanna come along ♪
♪ Word up, talk the talk,
just move like we off the wall ♪
♪ Day or night,
the sky's alight ♪
♪ So we dance
to the break of dawn ♪
♪ Ladies and gentlemen,
I got the medicine ♪
♪ So you should keep ya eyes
on the ball, huh ♪
♪ This is getting heavy ♪
♪ Can you hear the bass boom?
I'm ready ♪
♪ Life is sweet as honey ♪
♪ Yeah, this beat cha-ching
like money ♪
♪ Disco overload, I'm into that,
I'm good to go ♪
♪ I'm diamond,
you know I glow up ♪
♪ Let's go ♪
♪ 'Cause I-I-I'm
in the stars tonight ♪
♪ So watch me bring the fire
and set the night alight ♪
♪ Shining through the city
with a little funk and soul ♪
♪ So I'mma light it up
like dynamite, whoa ♪
♪ Dy-na-na-na, na-na, na-na-na,
na-na, life is dynamite ♪
♪ Shining through the city
with a little funk and soul ♪
♪ So I'mma light it up
like dynamite, whoa ♪
♪ Dy-na-na-na,
na-na, na-na, ayy ♪
♪ Light it up like dynamite ♪
♪ Dy-na-na-na,
na-na, na-na, ayy ♪
♪ Light it up like dynamite ♪
♪ 'Cause I-I-I'm
in the stars tonight ♪
♪ So watch me bring the fire
and set the night alight ♪
Hey!
♪ Shining through the city
with a little funk and soul ♪
♪ Light it up like dynamite ♪
♪ 'Cause I-I-I'm
in the stars tonight ♪
♪ So watch me bring the fire
and set the night alight ♪
♪ Shining through the city
with a little funk and soul ♪
♪ So I'mma light it up
like dynamite, whoa ♪
♪ Dy-na-na-na, na-na, na-na-na,
na-na, life is dynamite ♪
♪ Shining through the city
with a little funk and soul ♪
♪ Light it up
like dynamite, whoa ♪
♪♪